[Music]
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding welcome back to
the ginger lien podcast last episode of
the year I can't believe it the next
time you see us it'll be 20 20 20 20 20
20 y'all this episode is brought to you
by calm everybody just take a second
throughout your day to calm down with
calm the app it is an incredible app
that promotes mindfulness and helps
sleep right now you can get 40% off of a
compromise Jenna Julian that's 40% off
unlimited access to their entire library
it's a great app I use it all the time I
can't recommend it enough also guys the
skim helps you get in the know every
single day with a nice tidy newsletter
of all the top news stories right to
your email inbox completely free okay
seven million people currently use it
you should to go to the skim th es que I
am m.com slash annejulien enter email
subscribe completely free and you're in
and you're all to also enter to win a
tween River deal or Visa gift card when
you do that Thank You sponsors Thank You
sponsors all the dog goes want to be up
here this week they want it's a grand
finale of 2019 oh don't say that that's
too much pressure grand finale oh oh I
want to plan something better if I
thought of it that way
well Game of Thrones didn't so what I
said Game of Thrones didn't Wow but that
was not a grand finale it's like some
really cold tea you've just filled wait
I'm just my point is that a grand feller
doesn't have to be good it's just the
last one oh I see okay yeah it's just
the finale
got it yeah this is the finale season
whatever finale
Lacy's Wow yeah for real so this is this
podcast is the last one of the year then
we're taking two weeks off we're taking
time off for our minds mates and our
well-being and then we'll be back
January 6th I think is the next podcast
so you'll have to do without listening
to us talk I don't know how you're gonna
do that it's pretty much bare
Wow
also I think I straightened out the
frame I think we were a little off
centered now we're not the end by doing
good one
Jenna has a new thing we actually have
two new things we're gonna do this
episode is pretty fun
well yeah cuz I mean just do it all the
time anyways as it is so I was like I
don't know might as well make content
baby interested in all the things that I
Wikipedian this week I have a problem
like I've seen other people tweet it too
like this isn't what this list is but
like if I'm watching a show or like a
movie or anything like that and there's
an actor or something I'm like who's
that I go in and Wikipedia everything
about them like everything that's ever
happened in their life I'll use that I
don't know I'm just like a curious
person is that this curiosity yeah you
know yeah I get that I just want to know
more about people a lot of times it's
people and then sometimes or I guess
more often than I realize it's just like
random stuff well you got to take it
with a grain of sea salt right cuz it
might be just edited poorly and wrong
what Wikipedia it's not a hundred
percent right oh ya know whatever I'm
just gonna Cecil I like information yeah
Himalayan sea salt take it with a grain
of it do you ever just Wikipedia stuff
just sometimes yeah I mean I don't
really I don't so much Wikipedia stuff
as I just like google it and then I'm
like kind of wherever I feel like I
don't really end up on Wikipedia at a
time I either end up on like like IMDB I
go to a lot because I'm really
interested in like filmography cuz if I
see someone I'm like where they from
yeah you do that so much if you like the
way something is edited or something
like that you'll go and you'll look up
that person yeah like look at other
stuff they've done yeah but that other
things where I'm like that guy is such a
familiar face I need to know what he was
in there's something like that what like
Cher yeah she was in moonstruck do help
we talked about that we watched movie we
watched Moose Jaw moonstruck dude
such like such a good guys for all of
your suggestions I mean we were gonna
watch it anyway since we're on a quest
to watch every Nicolas Cage movie of all
time all-time and it came highly highly
recommended from Ali ah we watched over
Thanksgiving with my mom and it was sigh
it was so good it was like honestly a
[ __ ] genuinely amazing movie and I
it's like one of my favorite movies now
I was like crying laughing it was so
good it was good and Nicolas Cage was so
good in it and so we share like we we
like talked about how how goofy he is in
his later stuff especially all the bad
movies he's done but like this was a
really he did really good in this movie
and it was just such a beautiful movie
yeah I don't know it really was and I
really liked that the movie wasn't about
him yeah it was about sure it was about
Cher yeah I loved it but all the family
members every supporting actor actress
was like [ __ ] good man ten out of ten
yeah
special movie if you haven't watched
moonstruck we're passing on that
recommendation cuz it is good and I we
watched it with my mother so if you're
with your family and such a great guys
are looking for we wouldn't call it a
family movie yeah you know I don't
family I mean it's not even adult but
it's like yeah we watched with your mom
yeah I'm you know I wouldn't say it's a
you wouldn't want to watch it with like
your little cousins and stuff
you know it's a kid if you're a kid
you're gonna be bored by the movie yeah
there's some pigs in there it might be a
lot for a kid but ya know we it was a
good time yeah I had a good time
like I think part of what made it I mean
is a credible movie but I had just I
don't even know what my expectations
were they were low first of all because
I don't know I just I had low
expectations and also I just it's like
if for something about the movie it was
just like really unlike any movie I had
ever seen so I think it's always cool
when you see a film that like really
just kind of like I don't know like
Ben's what you think a movie can be in
your mind a little bit it was just so
different I don't know I really liked it
I liked it it felt like a play sometimes
yeah it did feel very much like a play
anyway I don't know how we got there but
how did we get there I don't know oh the
IMDB thing and looking up movies in
stuff yeah
did you look up the director of that
movie no but do you know remember how
excited i got when i were watching
Silicon Valley and one single frame
what Jillian does one single phrase was
uncolored and you had I had to like
pause and go into like quarter
frame-by-frame to see it but there was
one single frame that the colorist
didn't color and it was left in like
flat s log and it looked wrong but it
was so quick I was so excited that I
caught that oh my god he loves that
stuff and then I have to sit there for
20 minutes while you try and catch the
frame and Miss it like a hundred times
and then we're watching like survivor
they have really great people in time
lapses so when there's a good time lapse
I'll just be like these slaps these
slashes when he says swing every show if
there's ever time lips - slaps - slaps
and then when we were watching
moonstruck and there were those aerial
shots oh no it wasn't moonstruck we were
watching jingle all the way
and there were aerial shot what it oh
let me finish this point then we'll get
that we were watching jingle all the way
and it was made a long time ago and
there were aerial shots and I was like
yeah they [ __ ] had to have a
helicopter shoot that thing and just
like pointing out things like that but
yeah jingle all the way
I watched it when I was a child a lot
like during the holidays so for me
growing up I was like oh yeah jingle all
the way it's the pastime of mine I
watched it during the holidays and it
reminds me of the holidays as a child
how wonderful let's watch it and we
watched it right before moonstruck and
holy [ __ ] it is bad it's so bad and I
like I'm eating my words because I will
stand by the fact that stuck on you is
amazing okay you can go all the way
jingle all the way is a trash movie hold
on this is so not what I remember with
her mom and we're watching it like it's
opening up and my mom's like what do you
remember like liking about the movie you
know because we're having a great time
because it's [ __ ] bad we're just like
laughing at it because it shouldn't I am
and I remember when the movie came out
being like Arnold Schwarzenegger was a
big huge action star right and it was
like his equivalent of Dwayne the rock
Johnson doing the tooth fairy or
whatever this action star that's doing
this family movie and
it's like toys and kids and Christmas
and Arnold Schwarzenegger that's what I
remember like a fun toy action movie
about Christmas love it 10 out of 10 so
we're all like in this mindset being
like ok I'm sure it's gonna be 90s and
bad or whatever but please yeah yeah
it is so [ __ ] bad let me tell you
this story of jingle all the way is be a
[ __ ] dad do [ __ ] terrible [ __ ] things
to try and make up for [ __ ] dad you have
a perfect tornado of circumstances that
allow you to redeem yourself from being
a perfect like an absolute garbage dad
and that's it
all so be it [ __ ] dad do [ __ ] things and
then your kid will freak and then also
consumerism toys there's literally a
shot he's like he wants to get this toy
for his son because he forgot it's like
the most in-demand
toys we can't get it anywhere so that's
the plot he's just going around doing
awful things to get this toy that he
forgot to get his son and he's like in a
in a bar in the middle of the day
drinking because he's like defeated that
he can't get this toy it's Christmas Eve
and he's just drinking in a bar a diner
not even a bar yeah with this mailman
that he and he looks over the mailman
and for some reason he sees his son and
there's a actual shot of his son who's
supposed to be a child is a child in the
mail man's outfit like drinking his day
away there's a shot of a child taking
shots of whiskey and a flask or
something oh my god he's like oh no I
don't want my son to turn it was a toy
he feeds it a reindeer alcohol and he
also punches the same reindeer in the
face he like abuses that relates his
neighbor his house they blow up a
building with a bomb at one point and a
bunch of cops
but then the cops are like fine later
they just have like bandages on he tries
to take that bouncy ball from a child
and just goes this is my ball from the
top of them all
and then at the end he's just like
everything's redeemed because he's like
this he won't spoil her [ __ ] alert
here he becomes turbo man
and at the parade he acts out turbo man
he's he is him and all of the horrible
things that he's done to like drive his
wife into the arms of another man and
everything she's just like oh yeah like
where are you just on the phone with him
saying I'm tired of listening to you I'm
done I'm like pseudo breaking up for
like separating I don't know but I
really like so he goes through all the
trouble the entire movie to get this
stupid toy for his son and then his son
gives it to the mail at the end
who's going to prison by the way because
he gives it to the mill man yeah
the adult mailman yeah for his son so we
think yes he's like I want to give your
son the toy yeah because you know I
already have turbo man terminal is my
dad yeah
so the the son is like a better person
than the dad the entire movie entire
movie and that's it and then that's it
and then also during the finale like in
the parade
you see Arnold's character and he's just
like I could get used to this cuz he's
like the center of attention and he's
like this new superstar he like doesn't
give a [ __ ] about the fact that his kid
is like a lost in a crowd and now in
danger cuz he's being part of the show
but like B doesn't know where his [ __ ]
father is and he's just like yeah I
could get used to this it's terrible
it's terrible
it's like awful terrible movie and then
also something like a very small detail
that everyone seemed to like glaze over
but if you watch this movie in the final
scene where they're at the parade and
they're fighting over this doll which is
turbo man doll the doll is like 2.5
times bigger than the doll that he wants
and from the stores
it's like looks like an infant child
kind of it's like a very big version
like I don't know how you'd even play
with it all that big and that's the
that's the good doll when went in the
stores they come in like doll sized like
in a package like very similar it's like
that seems like kind of a big continuity
error that they would just have the
wrong size doll for the most important
see in the movie no idea where do we go
with this podcast sorry sorry anyway
jingle all the way don't watch it but
honestly if you want to watch a bad
movie with your family that's a great
bad movie to watch with your family it's
terrible I just like there were some
shocking moments
well hunches the reindeer and when the
building blows up from the bomb yeah
that's shocking I felt shocked I felt
shocked when there's a child drinking Oh
God
I felt shocked when that guy the
neighbor was just like very creepy Ted
was trying to steal his life the entire
movie is so ah the whole thing is just
so much okay anyways you want to know
something yeah give us some Wikipedia
things I want to hear what you've been
wick wicky-wicky
no no no that's not a choice okay I love
you for the last podcast you can sit
with me honey but you're gonna say so
this week I've been watching a lot of
ancient aliens again oh yeah going back
and stop it heaven no don't be sad I'm
not being sad I just I was just gonna
say that I've been waking up in the
middle of the night to it so I know
that's on
[Music]
hmm okay um I posted all these links in
my notes and now that I'm clicking on
them it's only allowing me to type so I
know the notes happens is frustrating
like that the first thing that I
wikipedia'd this week was the immortal
jellyfish
you ever heard of that nope now I have
to type it in and go find the article so
I would I did Wikipedia but some of
these are actual articles cuz they're a
little more interesting to read or like
better for us to understand what can you
give us is just a sentence back story I
was still why you did Wikipedia it okay
do you need to know why my thoughts get
to where they get to I would in general
like to know that well sometimes you
can't okay so the immortal jelly I have
never heard of this before even though I
have watched this episode of aliens but
they scientists discovered a jellyfish
jellyfish that can theoretically live
forever it's called a turritopsis
dohrnii
it's now officially known as the only
immortal creature the secret to eternal
life as it turns out is not just living
a really really long time
it's about maturity or rather the lack
of it the immortal jellyfish as is
better known popularly propagate and
then faced with the normal career path
of dying they opted instead to revert to
a sexually immature stage turns out that
once the adult form of the four point
five millimeter wide species have
reproduced they don't die but transform
themselves back into their juvenile
polyp state their tentacles retract
their bodies shrink and they sink to the
ocean floor and start the cycle all over
again for among laboratory samples all
the adult Pteropus
observed regularly undergo this change
and not just once they can do it over
and over again thus the only known way
they can die is that they get consumed
by another fish or if a disease strikes
the jelly however there are so many
mysteries surrounding the Pteropus door
and I - all the process of reverting
from its adult phase to a polyp was
observed several times it hasn't been
observed observed yet in nature only in
laboratory environments so it's the
Benjamin Button jellyfish yeah it just
reverts to being young again yeah and
then it starts over like it's a video
game yeah that's so crazy
does it shed part of its body or
something just said that its tentacles
retract into its body and it turns
himself into a polyp again that's so
efficient Wow good for them but it has
reproduced so it made other jellyfish no
that's like literally living a full life
having a family about a diet at a
hundred you're like exactly let's do it
again
but now like imagine it in your okay
this is totally made-up you have a
little fish tank filled with immortal
jellyfish start with one yeah it's
reproduced and then all of a sudden it
sinks to the bottom and it's a little
polyp but you have like four now and how
do you tell what the babies are and what
the Benjamin Button one is you got to
keep track of you got to teach them
their name yeah you got teaching his
name keep track of which ones okay
that's [ __ ] interesting isn't it
that's cool I want to be him you want to
be him yeah but like there's no other
species that were aware of on earth that
can revert back to a sexually immature
stage and start its lifecycle with or
without like dividing itself into a part
of itself it becomes a part of a new
being like you know me Byers yeah yeah
don't they die eventually I think what I
think parts of them do but I think parts
of them move on or something I don't
know
I'm not mathematician but I don't think
they revert to a sexually immature stage
like that's a really intense process
yeah how do you do that I don't know
jellyfish be Wyland anyways wouldn't you
a jellyfish but you also Benjamin Button
it's like it's just really interesting
like how do you even
I wonder why what do you do with that
information like why can you figure out
how they do that how but why how about
why
huh okay so this next thing that I
wikipedia'd but it's more like fan
wikipedia'd whatever the fandom I
literally was sleepy yeah whatever
I was playing elder scrolls play oh hey
you know I'm sorry I'm sorry
cut I was playing elder scrolls with a
friend of mine who's in one of my guilds
and she was telling me how she's super
into My Little Pony which I've heard
some people are I just had no idea how
popular it was and I've heard that it's
all like the people that I don't know
what they call himself I'm sorry if I'm
being ignorant but they love My Little
Pony so much because it's about magic
and friendship have you heard that
before
not until you told me they love it okay
and adults yes they love the show the
books and that it's so big that there is
something called well there's a lot of
like fan fictions like independently
written stories about the My Little Pony
universe indifferent whatever this this
one particular one is called fallout
Equestria like the game fallout
Equestria West Rio with My Little Pony
like characters so all of the individual
fan fictions usually focus on one of the
ponies which teaches you one specific
thing about life yeah so like one of
them is about this pony and her journey
while she learns her purpose in life is
to sacrifice herself for all of her
friends at all costs whereas another one
might be about persistence and one of
the ponies has to learn that her job and
life is to just be persistent now costs
so my friend was telling me how she
loves this series called follow
Equestria and I was like what is that
like a book like well what is that she
was like it's an independently written
fanfiction but listen to this fallout
Equestria is a crossover fanfiction
between My Little Pony Friendship is
Magic television series and the fallout
video game series which was written by
k-kat because I was like who the hell is
the author who was writing these
fanfiction this person's name is KCAP
first published in April 2011 and
completed on Christmas of that year
fallout Equestria spans forty five
chapters as well as a prologue
introduction epilogue and afterward and
contains over six hundred and twenty
thousand words making fallout Equestria
one of the longest self-published works
of derivative fiction in existence
that's insane
that is so insane that amount of words
and then she was telling me there's
another one that has over a million
words so I was like you know I'm getting
my mind look a little bit like this is a
fanfiction yeah that is six hundred and
twenty thousand words long so I was like
that's crazy I've I don't even really
remember the last time that I read like
a book that was that long or anything
like that that was that long you know I
don't I'm honestly I don't think I ever
have and she was like I don't really
read them I listen to them on YouTube
and I was like I gotta check this out
there's literal YouTube channels that
are devoted to reading the fanfiction
and their posts are like three hours
long and it'll do like three chapters
that is an entire world I had no idea
about that's what I'm saying
yeah the largest derivative fanfiction
series that exists is fallout Equestria
or one of the largest that's crazy
fallout Equestria I was like did you
ever play fallout and she's like yeah
but I'm like it's not that's not the
important part
it's the pony part it's the yeah fallout
it's more like the world that's in or
whatever yeah that's so funny right yeah
so I googled what that was or I guess
Wikipedia but that was well like look at
all these chapters like it's just it
goes on and on and on and on and on that
is insane Wow I just I had many chapters
I know I had and this is just one of
them there's so many other ones yeah but
I had no idea that people wrote fan
fictions from like TV series that were
anywhere near this long yeah or had this
type of following yeah that's nuts
that's just dedication I mean there's
that level of like interest you know in
a world a fictitious world that people
want to
derivative content that's so intense
yeah I mean for those of you that are
having liked it even a hard time
understanding what that is it's like if
you liked Game of Thrones if somebody
wrote a million word fanfiction about
Game of Thrones in a Minecraft
background yeah that's the equivalent
yeah that's that's insane
that's so wild right yeah I had no idea
yeah it was a thing anyways I got my
mind blowing when she told me that
alright the next thing that I
wikipedia'd from watching ancient aliens
was the Akashic records have you ever
heard of that nope
alright I'll read this directly from
Wikipedia hit me I don't know how to say
this word in theosophy
that word sounds awesome you sound smart
y'all Sofia and and through inter fossa
pee you know what okay the Akashic
records are a compendium of all human
events thoughts words emotions and
intent ever to have occurred in the past
present or future they're believed to be
encoded in a non-physical plane of
existence called the etheric plane there
are anecdotal accounts but there is no
scientific evidence for the existence of
the Akashic records what the heck what
so it doesn't exist on a physical plane
what does that even mean yeah so well I
had to look it up on Wikipedia even
though there's more questions than
answers yeah when you look on Wikipedia
but in ancient aliens basically what
they described it as is a record of
everything that's ever existed all of
your memories all of my memories all of
everyone's memories of everything that's
ever existed all of their thoughts all
of their intense God everything it's
where we're all connected to a cosmic
consciousness that is the collection of
all of our consciousnesses put together
so like everything that you're living
goes into this cosmic consciousness
that there are people that have tapped
into the Akashic records by God like
meditating or you know existing in it
what do they call it um etheric plane
that you can actually access it at some
point if you're like I don't know who's
the person who that we got they can get
their Deepak Chopra I don't know who can
get there someone's gotta be super
[ __ ] outside of themselves to get
there right there like elevate yourself
yeah but that I didn't know that there
was a word or like it's like the library
of humanity mm-hmm that exists on a
non-human plane of existence what what
sighs server do you think it is huge
how many terabytes amazingly large
billions of terabytes literally I mean
imagine dude every thought that everyone
has ever had em hmm how do you even
organize that how do you tap into that
well think about how big the universe is
listen here's my the Akashic record
isn't even just human existence like all
beings of everywhere and everything in
every universe what what it what if like
what if you are just you're meditating
one day and you're just getting there
you're out there right you're like
really Levitt like levitating your mind
to a different place because you're
meditating so dope yeah right yeah and
you start seeing really calm get the
clap and you start to hear or see or
like experience thoughts and like how do
you know that that's where you are that
you're at the Akashic records and you're
not just like experiencing random
thoughts that are in the you know I feel
like if you are anywhere close to
experiencing the Akashic records you
don't have questions so what you just
ask
fair enough they just know you're like
oh my god what are these thoughts know
you've already surpassed that well I
feel like it's one of those things that
if you once you get there if you're if
you're the person that can even reach
that you already know where you are yeah
that's what I'm saying yeah so
in the wikipedia is there any
documentation of someone who claims to
have reached it and it will talk not in
the wicked mmm that's [ __ ] great dude
speaking of meditation can I go for it
Julian download the call map today it is
a great app it helps with guided
meditation mindfulness sleep it has
something called the daily calm right so
you open up the calm app on your phone
it's really great you just pop it open
okay and you press daily calm and you
pop in your air pods or your earphones
your wireless whatever whatever you
listen or you just play it through your
iPhone speaker or whatever it is and it
walks you through a mindfulness routine
where you really are able to at least
for me center yourself become aware of
your thoughts and just kind of separate
your mind from all of what's going on in
your life whether it's work or
relationships or what's on your phone or
what you have to do today or
responsibilities or stresses for the 10
minutes you really and this is just the
daily calm it's just one of the things
they offer they have a whole library of
different activities 60 million people
use them but anyway for those 10 minutes
for me at least I'm able to really just
hone in on my brain and like my thoughts
and for me that's so powerful because I
feel like I could go so many days and
weeks and moments without being mindful
and it catches up and I start to feel a
little bit crazy and I feel like I'm
kind of losing you know myself in ways
of just becoming more aware of what's
going on in my head and so with the
comma it is a really great experience
and right now you guys can get 40% off
the comm premium subscription when you
go to calm calm CA LM comm slash Jenna
Julianne I would highly recommend it you
can also try the free trial or the free
version when you just download the calm
app I give it a shot let us know what
you think highly highly recommend and
also guys the skim it is an amazing
daily newsletter that you can sign up
for and in five minutes you can skim the
most important news of the day good news
bad news whatever it is they give you
the the bullet points of what's going on
in the world
that you are better off knowing so right
now go to th es ki mm that's two M's com
/ Jenna Julian or click the link in the
description enter your email and click
Subscribe and then you're done it's
completely free and all you have to do
is open the skin on your email when it
comes in in the morning grab a cup of
coffee and educate yourself that's all
it is it's very easy to read easy to
digest it's not convoluted with other
things and opinions and this and that it
just gives you what you need so check it
out and also when you subscribe to the
skin newsletter you are now entered to
win a $250 Visa gift card which you can
spend wherever you want
thank you sponsors thank you sponsors
anyway the akashic record-- that is
intriguing to me mm-hmm that reminds me
of like your watch interstellar yeah
watched it with you oh I remember if I
watched you but um do you remember when
spoilers okay when they're he's like
traveling through like space and time
right and he gets to that like what is
it's like inside the closet or something
do you know what I what seeing him
referring to and he's like there's all
these different dimensions around him
that's what I picture the Akashic
records that's like what's popped into
my brain when you described it well yeah
and I mean according to some of this too
it's like not just what has happened in
the past but what is going to happen in
the future that make sense yes some of
them aren't entirely clear it's sort of
like a ship ting synergy of what could
happen got it like you're tapping into
like a radio frequency of just about
whatever but then I mean I'm reading
very confusing stuff because I think
it's a confusing topic you know cuz no
one knows so it's all just what anyone
thinks so there I see a lot of language
that is like how do you access your
Akashic records which would be like all
of your lifetimes and all of your
thoughts and all of your intents and
that for supplies I guess that your soul
has lived before and that will live
again so you're accessing something that
you that is personalized to you do you
mean a
I think the definition of it is like a
cosmic total totality of everyone's
consciousness for sure even animals and
anything sentient yeah but the base idea
is that everyone sort of has their own
every being would have one no I think
it's just a thought maybe people have an
individual Akashic record and that
there's a bigger I don't know yeah what
do you know why it has that name um I
mean I know it's not maybe I was curious
where it came from but that's super
[ __ ] interesting good it's a Sanskrit
word for ether sky or atmosphere that's
pretty cool okay next thing soul the
panels on the moon don't look down and
look disinterested it's a good time are
you ready yeah did you get this
information aliens - yeah no when I see
something in ancient aliens and you know
they'll just like glaze over it and I'm
like I want to actually read a little
more about that
I'll just go google it that's what a
phone is for exactly so this this comes
from the NASA website or something that
looks like NASA dot know it is gum so is
it yeah okay this is the Luna ring
concept the Luna ring electric power
generated by a belt of solar cells
around the lunar equator could be
transmitted and beamed to the earth from
the near side of the moon
[ __ ] yes so this is a real thing that I
think it was a Japanese construction
company was seriously considering well
I'll worry I'll read this and I'll tell
you what I know this shim the Shimizu
Corporation and Japanese construction
firm has recently proposed and I don't
know what year this was published but
recently whenever this is published a
plan to harness solar energy on a larger
scale than almost any previously
proposed concept their ambiguous plan
involves
a belt of solar cells around the moon's
6,800 mile or 11,000 kilometer equator
converting the electricity to powerful
microwaves and lasers to be beamed to at
earth and finally converting the beams
back to electricity or terrestrial power
stations or at terrestrial power
stations the lunar in concept
the company says could meet the entire
world's energy needs
holy-shit robots would play the primary
role in building the lunar ring tella
operated 24 hours a day from the earth
the robots would be tella operated from
earth to level the lunar landscape and
assemble machines and equipment in orbit
before they are landed on the moon a
team of astronauts would support the
robots on site due to the massive amount
of solar panels and other materials
needed for the project lunar resources
would be used to the fullest extent
possible water could be produced near
the equator by reducing lunar soil with
hydrogen imported from Earth lunar
resources would also be used to make
cementing material and concrete while
solar heat treatments could help produce
bricks glass fibers and structural
materials needed for the project the
lunar ring itself would initially have a
width of a few kilometers but could be
extended up to 400 kilometers wide the
electric power generated by solar cells
would be transmitted by electric cables
to transmission facilities on the near
side of the moon while which is
constantly facing earth after the
electricity is converted into microwave
beams and laser beams 20 kilometer
diameter antennas would beam the power
to receivers on earth a guidance radio
beacon would ensure accurate
transmission to receivers
I'm just trying to read this like
actually viable or not or if they're
actually moving forward with it or what
oh yeah whatever okay so but the idea is
we are dealing with some energy issues
yeah some renewable resource issues and
climate issues this basically is
proposing a way to beam unlimited clean
energy down to earth from the moon
because the moon is always getting
sunlight and a lot brighter and a lot
better sunlight than the earth gets
because they have no atmosphere oh and
just beaming it down to us that was my
question is why they have better
that's [ __ ] crazy dude thinking about
the thinking about remote operating
robots from earth to moon that is
responsible on that okay so imagine they
build this thing right and in like 150
years the earth has now run 100 percent
off of energy from the moon diffractive
refracted from the Sun right and there's
an issue imagine being the tech support
guy who's responsible for programming
the robot to fix whatever issue is and
all that the only thing that depends on
it is all of Earth's energy like that is
so insane to me
it's so cool to think about though right
like any would just beam the energy over
and like so you say you mentioned
something about converting the energy
back to like usable electricity
electricity so you think about how many
people have solar panels like California
is a state that will give you what tax
the dark tax deductions if you are using
a house that has solar panels that kind
of stuffs they're incentivizing people
to you have solar panels but the problem
with solar panels is even in California
which is a very sunny place you still
have cloudy days you still have
nighttime you know you still have times
when your solar panel isn't getting you
any power if you put it in a place where
there it's getting constant like really
all the time all the time that's [ __ ]
while you could have enough power in
theory to power the entire world you
know where I see that being more
realistic in like a like if I if I could
imagine reading something about this in
the future that actually happens is not
a way for the entire world to get their
energy from the moon but rather like a
premium energy subscription that only
super [ __ ] rich people could afford
the energy off like a handful of solar
panels on the moon or ones that were in
outer space right that's terrible isn't
that scary though but that's not
something I could imagine right like
they think you're sizing well corporate
izing it but also like they couldn't
quite scale it right away
to like
serve the whole world so only the elite
can afford it or something right and
there's only X amount of them and so
then like yes like all everyone who is
struggling with the energy crisis on
earth has to worry about that except for
like the super [ __ ] rich people who
are getting it from the moon yeah
imagine that that's crazy
that's super interesting though right so
the belt of panels right the one that
you described on the moon that would go
around the entire moon like as like a
ring kind of hmm and so every every
single second there's some energy being
absorbed hmm that's so cool imagine what
the moon would look like with that thing
on it it would have a fancy belt so cute
so cute it would look so cute at night
with this little boat that is just like
tripping me out to think about it right
yeah
BAM anyways I thought that was really
cool I like that one and I mean I don't
know how viable it is or how much
they're doing that seriously but I do
know that that's a theory that exists
which i think is a really cool theory
like what a brilliant thought is it
brilliant [ __ ] and then Here I am just
sitting on this but I'm sitting on this
one like what am i contributing to
humanity except a giant [ __ ]
never-ending distraction you welcome
okay I seriously like keep myself up at
night sometimes I'm like am I just
contributing to the cultural distraction
of a terrible person okay the next thing
that I have a Wikipedia where Japanese
water demons oh called Gappa this is
directly from Wikipedia a Kappa
or River child also known as Kawa taro ,
he ki mm-hmm Oh
Kawa taro is River boy , he ki is horse
polar kaltura is River tiger and Sui Co
or water tiger is an amphibious yokai
demon or imp found in traditional
I like it there's a lot of imps in the
Elder Scrolls found in traditional jet
fuels when you make tarkov jokes found
in traditional Japanese folklore they
are typically depicted as green
human-like beings with webbed hands and
feet in green is horn turtle like shell
on their backs
alright here's the most interesting part
you ready a depression on its head
called it's dish or sara retains water
and if this is damaged or let's liquid
is lost
either through spilling or drying up the
Kappa is severely weakened okay so it's
pretty much a water bowl it's a water
bowl so to defeat it you say peachy you
thirsty because the water rocks it even
water bowl oh my god alright why is it
called a demon though or why is it a it
will listen okay sorry
the Kappa are known to favor cucumbers
young and cute I'd love to engage in
sumo wrestling fun
they are often accused of assaulting
humans in water and removing a mythical
organ called the I'm trying really hard
shiri Kodama from their victims eNOS
oh so it goes to the butt mm-hmm
what is a mythical organ there I guess
they're talented I've I wanna Incheon
aliens that's where I saw them they
speak even though they had like a beak
and they the people used to tell their
kids to stay away from water because
there's kapa in them and that they're
like I'm all right I'm gonna take your
sheer ekodama from you now remember and
then they do BUTT STUFF but they're like
oh hi doctor my you know I'm ethical
Oregon it really hurts to have any
medicine for that appearance just think
that self-learning the word mythical
Oregon the Kappa is said to be roughly
humanoid informed and about the size of
a child inhabiting the ponds and rivers
of Japan is typically greenish
color or yellow blue in either scaly or
slimy skinned with webbed hands and feet
and turtle like shell on its back one
particular trait is that as a cavity on
its head it retains water or some sort
of liquid which is regarded as the
source of the Kappas power or lifeforce
this cavity must be full whenever a
Kappa is away from the water if it ever
dries out or the water is spilled Kappa
loses its power and may even die the
Kappa are sometimes cell said to smell
like fish and they can swim like them
according to some accounts its arms are
connected to each other through the
torso and can slide from one side to the
other so arms can just like spin around
look well they are primarily water
creatures they do on occasion venture
onto land when they do the dish on their
head can be covered with a metal cap for
protection a metal cap a metal cap
behavior Kappa are usually seen as
mysterious troublemakers or trickster
figures yeah they don't sound straight
up at all mmm these shifty their actions
range from comparatively minor such as
looking up women's kimonos mmm no no no
to the outright malevolence such as
drowning people or animals kidnapping
children raping women and at times
eating human flesh
oh those sometimes menacing it may also
behave amicably towards humans
thank you peach all right here's a whole
section on cucumber folk beliefs claimed
the cucumber as their traditional
favorite meal at festivals offerings of
cucumber are frequently made to the
Kappa sometimes the Kappa is said to
have other favorite foods such as the
Japanese eggplant soba fermented
soybeans sushi kabocha in Edo old Tokyo
there used to be a tradition where
people would write the names of their
family members on cucumbers and send
them afloat
into the streams to mollify the Kappa to
prevent the family from coming in to
harm in the streams own regions it was
customary to eat cucumbers before
swimming as
action but in others it was believed
that this act would guarantee an attack
yeah wouldn't that make you smell and
taste like cucumber so they would want
you well this is cool listen to this a
cucumber filled sushi roll is known as a
Kappa Maki oh my god I think I've
actually seen that name on menus there
you go cuz the tuna rolls Tekka Maki Oh
YUM fun as water monsters Kappa have
been blamed for drownings and are often
said to try to lure people into water
and pull them in with their great skill
at wrestling family wrestling wrestle a
sumo wrestle they're sometimes said to
take their victims for the purposes of
drinking their blood eating their livers
are gaining powers by taking their
Sheree Sheree Kodama a mythical ball
said to contain the soul which is
located inside a tiss have been used to
warn children of the dangers of lurking
in rivers and lakes as Kappa have been
often said to try to lure people to
water to pull them in even today science
warning about Kappa appeared by bodies
of water in some Japanese towns and
villages like there's literally a
picture of a child getting pulled under
imagine like visiting though with your
kids and being like what the [ __ ] is
going on in this lake so I was wondering
what it looked like this drawing of it
makes it look like a fish person there's
other pictures you can you can Wikipedia
in your own how big are they how big are
they did you already said I know I
forget toppy or like child size okay cap
are also said to victimize dude
especially horses and cows the motif of
the Kappa trying to drown a horse is
found all over Japan
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh Oh defeating the
Kappa okay here's a picture that you can
look at of the BUTT STUFF with the
soldier oh yeah there you go it was
believed that they were a few means of
escape if one was confronted with a
Kappa Kappa are obsessed with politeness
so if a person makes a deep bow it will
return the gesture this results in the
Kappa spilling the water held in the
dish on its head rendering it unable to
leave the bowing position until the
plate is refilled with water from the
river in which it lives if a person
refills it the Kappa will serve that
person for all eternity is similar
weakness of the Kappa involves its arms
which can easily be pulled from his body
if an arm is detached the Kappa will
perform favors or share knowledge in
exchange for its return tell me your
secrets Kappa another method to defeat
of defeat involves shogi or sumo
wrestling a Kappa sometimes challenges a
human being a human being to wrestle or
engage in other tests of skill
here you go Julian this tendency is
easily used to encourage the Kappa to
spill the water from its Sarah one
notable example of this method is the
folktale of a farmer farmer who promised
his daughter's hand in marriage to a
Kappa in return for the creature
irrigating is his land what the heck
kind of dad is that a farmer's daughter
challenges the Kappa to submerge several
gourds in water when the Kappa fails in
its task it retreats saving the farmer's
daughter from marriage Kappa i've also
been driven away from their aversion to
iron sesame or ginger oh I like ginger
all right here's some good deeds cap are
not entirely antagonistic to human
beings once befriended Kappa may perform
any number of tasks for human beings
such as helping farmers irrigate their
land sometimes they bring fresh fish
which is regarded as a mark of good
fortune for them family that receives it
they're also highly knowledgeable about
medicine and legend states that they're
taught of the art of bone setting to
human beings what I want to know is like
so they're underwater most of the time
right they can come out but they're
underwater most of the time right how do
you sumo wrestle underwater and if you
do somewhere else
well you don't land you can't defeat
them cuz they put the damn metal cap on
the head and they can't you can't pour
the water out take the cap off it's a
metal cap it's like a tank mm-hmm that's
super crazy it seems to be very like
widely I don't know like known in
Japanese culture because of my shows in
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles 3 Leonardo
Michelangelo Donatello and Raphael are
mistaken for capital when they're
teleported back in time to feudal Japan
no way is that real it's real in a movie
yeah but that movie is a documentary I
thought oh yeah it's a document ok are
you ready for the last one yeah yeah hit
me hit me hit me which really sent me on
a fun trip ok so your girl was looking
at nikola tesla's personal life on
wikipedia okay
boy is it a good time you want it you
want to hear a portrait of a man I give
you a portrait of a men personal life
Tesla was six feet tall two inches
weight a hundred and forty two pounds
with almost no weight variance from 1888
to about 1926 his appearance was
described by newspaper editor Arthur
Brisbane is almost the tallest almost
the thinnest and certainly the most
serious man who goes to Delmonico's
regularly he was an elegant stylish
figure
stylish figure in New York City
meticulous and his grooming clothing and
regimented in his daily activities and
appearance he maintained as further his
business relationship he was also
described as having light hand or light
eyes very big hands and remarkably big
thumbs Tesla read many works memorize
incomplete books and supposedly
possessed a photographic memory he was a
polygon speaking eight languages several
creation Czech English French German
Hungarian Italian and Latin bark Tesla
related his autobiography related in his
autobiography that he experienced
detailed moments of inspiration during
his early life Tesla was repeatedly
stricken with illness
I remember all that but that's not the
good part I'm getting to the good part
he has picture thinking bla bla bla bla
bla picture thinking picture thinking
relationships Tesla never married
explaining that his chastity was very
helpful to his scientific abilities he
once said in his earlier years that he
felt he could never be worthy enough for
a woman
considering women superior in every way
ok I'm on board
ready I'm on board Tesla pre wish you
his opinion had started to sway in later
years when he felt that women were
trying to outdo men and make themselves
more dominant this quote new woman was
met with much indignation from Tesla who
felt that women were losing their
femininity by trying to be in power in
an interview the Galveston Daily News on
August 10 1924 he stated in place of the
soft voice gentle woman of my reverent
worship has come the woman who thinks
that her chief success and life lies in
making herself as much possible like man
in dress voice and actions and sports
achievements of every kind the tendency
of women to push aside men supplanting
the old spirit of cooperation with him
in all their affairs of life is very
disappointing to me although he told a
reporter in later years that he
sometimes felt that by not marrying he
had not made he had made too great a
sacrifice to his work
Tesla chose to never pursue or engage in
any known relationships instead fine
finding all the stimulation he needed in
his work Tesla was antisocial and prone
to seclude himself with his work however
when he did engage in social life many
people spoke positively and admiring Lee
of Tesla Robert Underwood Johnson
described him as distinguished with a
sweetness sincerity modesty refinement
generosity in force I'm trying to get to
the good part some good there's some
good stuff in here give me a second hit
me with that bit that's a good time when
you stimulated by your job Tesla could
be harsh at times and openly expressed
disgust for overweight people such as
when he fired his secretary because of
her weight he was quick to criticize
clothing on several occasions
Tesla directed us
ordinate to go home and change her dress
when Thomas Edison died in 1931 Tesla
contributed the only negative opinion to
the New York Times buried in an
extensive coverage of Edison's life this
is what he wrote he had no hobby cared
for no sort of amusement of any kind and
lived an utter disregard of the most
elementary rules of Hygiene his method
was was inefficient in the extreme for
an immense ground had to be covered to
get anything at all unless blind chance
intervened and at first I was almost a
sorry witness of his doings knowing that
just a little theory and calculation
would have saved him 90% of the labor oh
my god but he had a variable veritable
contempt for book learning and
mathematical knowledge trusting himself
entirely to his inventors instinct and
practical American sense toxic right oh
my god sleep habits Tesla claimed to
never sleep more than two hours per
night however he did admit to quote
dozing from time to time to quote
recharge his batteries during his second
year of study at gras' Tesla developed a
passionate proficiency for billiards
chess and card playing sometimes
spending more than 48 hours in his
stretch at a gaming table my guy was the
gaming you know what I'm saying
on one occasion at his laboratory Tesla
worked for a period of 84 hours without
rests Kenna's Swasey a journalist with
whom Tesla had befriended confirmed that
Tesla rarely slept he recalled one
morning Tesla called him at 3:00 a.m. I
was sleeping in my room like one dead
suddenly the telephone rang and awakened
me he was just he never sleeps he worked
every day from 9 a.m. to 6 p.m. or later
with dinner exactly at 8:10 p.m. at
Delmonico's restaurant and later the
Waldorf Astoria Hotel Tesla would
telephone his dinner order to the head
waiter it would also be the only one to
serve him the meal was required to be
ready at 8 o'clock he dined alone except
on the rare occasion when he would give
a dinner to a group to meet his social
obligations what Tesla would then resume
his work off until 3:00 a.m. for
exercise Tesla walked between
ten miles a day once when he curled his
toes 100 times for each foot each night
saying that it stimulated his brain
cells toe curls tall curls
what the heck toe curls for the girls
them girls like them strong toes she was
a gamer he loved women until he hated
women yeah never was with one I want to
try to--'cause because if that
stimulates his brain I probably work
right yeah but so does never sleeping
and there's a whole part about him
getting really sick a lot yeah which
probably has to do the fact that he's
never [ __ ] sleeping or like doing
anything other than walking and eating
at Delmonico's at 8 p.m. Julian no I
just curl my toe and he was like low-key
dick huh the Heike dick hide he put butt
in in the de Thomas Edison thing oh my
god horrible it's so easy cells like
what it's unnecessary what's going on
with you my guy my guy my guy just take
a nap my guy guy he's dead dude just let
it go just like taking that for a week
or two my guy if you ain't got nothing
nice to say about Thomas Edison
considered just saying nothing at all my
god
yeah he was a gamer but he was toxic he
was a toxic guy he's a toxic
non-sleeping gamer they had no time for
women except to tell him to go home and
change the [ __ ] dress curling his
toes walking ten miles a day only one
person can serve him at Delmonico's
that's so wild right yeah that was a
real that was a real personality 142
pounds you live like that dude he was
just very busy I mean we're all grateful
to all of the things that he's
contributed to us
so I mean you live your life however you
gotta live it in order to get all those
thoughts so it's pretty great stuff
yeah like men we're not gonna forget
what you did my guys you did my guy Tom
real dirty
he was the first toxic gamer who's the
first ever toxic gamer that's who he is
you toxic yeah [ __ ] terrible that's
so crazy and interesting like what to
think about that is wild I just like
reading stuff like that cuz I'm like wow
alright I should start Wikipedia things
cuz I was genuinely interested in
everything you brought up like I well
thank you but I mean think I was more
like it's just interesting why do you
think I sit around and looks up up all
the time how do you think my brain is
filled with the worst stupid dominus
information ever
I just can't a lot of rooms open I keep
jamming dumb stuff in there I can't stop
sometimes I just leave it empty okay
thanks so I want to I can just hear
myself really low dose a now it was
really fun we had another segment but
we'll do it another episode yeah for me
that was really cool I love the idea of
just getting lost and Wikipedia all that
I did it's cool the what is it the the
library one the Akasha Akashic records
that one is [ __ ] crazy mm-hmm that
one's one that's gonna keep me up at
night I'm gonna like actually be
thinking about that when I'm trying to
fall asleep cool it's gonna be hard to
fall asleep I already have a hard time
falling asleep
well not falling asleep staying asleep
but calm anyway guys thank you for
another year of really great podcasts we
we appreciate you guys more than we
could ever say oh real for real thank
you for supporting the podcast like you
have for so long and it's crazy that
we're moving on to 2020 I can honestly
can't believe it like I can't believe it
either
can't believe it for a lot of reasons
what year is it where am i what am i
doing what are we [ __ ] doing out here
dude I really really hope you guys all
have a wonderful holiday and some time
off spend it with the people you love
and we'll see you guys in January for a
fresh bright new year full of content
but yeah just a big thank you you guys
for supporting thank you guys so happy
holidays we love you see you in two
weeks see you in two weeks
Happy New Year I'll be right by guys
[Music]
[Music]